should be a transmitter around here
signal's clear
i should ask genki about building some
sort of underground adblock
ugh
whatever
this could be useful
really christmas
give me the hammer get here that's what
i'm talking about
yeah you are the man
in criminal news sounds like there's a
weapons deal happening near you
don't think those guns are for paintball
those better be water guns if they're
not
guessing
and that's one more arms deal stopped in
progress
good work me
okay
hey miles
this combat challenge is all about the
art of the dodge
defeat the enemies while taking as
little damage as possible three hits and
you'll have to restart step into the
circle when you're ready good luck
three hits okay got this
let's practice the perfect dash just try
dodging possibly
this yours
[Music]
that's a lot of guys
ancient enemies incoming watch out for
gunfire
more enemies
that was close
keep it up repeat doesn't make it easy
you guys take returns
watch out for
gunfire look out
i keep doing it
that's a lot of guys
watch out for gunfire holding the
trigger look out
fast
more enemies
that's a lot of guys
enemies on the field
incoming
doesn't make it easy
all right
let's do this
degrees
you're the ultimate miles what else is
there to say
nice work
feels like
new skills here
remember
you can one hit ko enemies after a
perfect dodge it's pretty handy just
saying
one hit ko
gotta try that out
hey danicasters
a lot of you have questions about
roxanne such as who are they and why do
they suck so much so let me give you a
quick rundown
simon krieger took over after inventing
a new form
[Applause]
got two words for you air combat in this
challenge enemies only take damage while
airborne get as many airborne kos as
possible approach the prompt when you're
ready air combat oh i got this
and the crowd goes up
can't stand the heat
and the crowd goes wild
down he goes
pete's right
way more control up here
can't stand the heat get out the airport
kick it
and the crowd goes wild
[Music]
airborne valet up here
there miles
he's right way more control up here
some classical music would go great with
this like a waltz a waltz with punches
[Music]
more like
this is
air box
oh
spider-man
when there's no
you could listen to pete spiderman shot
talk all day dude is good at this job
target employee aerial tactics
i now between the title of ultimate to
you miles nicely done
[Music]
now i know many of you brush heads love
to listen to the show on your subway
commute
i personally do my best to avoid setting
foot in those feces-infested death tubes
but jared informs me that a major outage
recently stopped all trains going
through harlem i'm happy to report that
service to the area has
since been fully restored
the main purpose of stealth saving lives
free all the hostages without being
spotted to win this challenge
time is a factor so move quick
zip to the prompt to get stealthy
passages eh sounds tense
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very beat
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very pete
are you what
oh right
fake people
bet you didn't see that coming
you'll never get away with this evil
holograms
i knew you'd save me my um spiderman
amazing love
it's the time
they spotted you sorry miles
they saw
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
weird
very beat
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
kind of weird
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
you dastardly holograms aren't ready for
spider-man
oh thank you spider-man are you up
oh right
passive detection sensors
great takedown very strategic
possible disturbance detected
[Music]
you'll never get away with this evil
holograms
i knew you'd save me my um spiderman
amazing
i spotted you sorry
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
kind of weird
man this hostage position is really
uncomfortable
oh thank you spider-man are you up
oh right
normal
possible disturbance detected
possible disturbance initiating
investigation
auditory disturbance detected
[Music]
great takedown
sorry
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very pete
oh thank you spiderman are you up
oh right stay people
it looks so peaceful knocked out
another one bites the dust
don't ever get away with this evil
holograms
i you'd save me my um spiderman
amazing lovely
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very beat
oh thank you spiderman are you up
oh right
that'll leave a mark
possible disturbance initiating
investigation
auditory disturbance detected
possible disturbance detected
auditory alert possible intruder
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete that's
funny
weird
very beat
they saw me
we can take down guys while crawling on
walls too
man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
kind of weird
very beat
you dastardly holograms aren't ready for
spider-man
oh right
fake people
auditory districts
you can take down guys while crawling on
walls too
man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
remember you can take down guys while
sliding on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very peter
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very beat
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very beat
multiple disturbances
oh thank you spiderman are you're well
oh right
fake people
possible
foreign
remember you can take down guys while
throwing on walls too
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
and weird
very beat
auditory alert possible
got it great takedown very strategic
here
possible disturbance initiating
investigation
man this hostage position is really
uncomfortable
oh thank you spiderman are you up
oh right
take people
don't ever get away with this evil
holograms
i knew you'd save me my um spiderman
investigation alert
remember you can take down
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
very peter
initiating investigation
oh thank you spiderman are you up
oh right
fake people
[Music]
alert
and this hostage position is really
uncomfortable
i knew you'd save me my um spiderman
amazing love
attempting to locate
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls
oh man the hostages are all pete
that's funny
weird
very beat
auditory alert possible intruder
multiple disturbance detectives
[Music]
oh right
fake people
you'll never get away with this evil
holograms
[Music]
amazing love
sequence initiated
possible disturbance initiating
investigation alert possible hostile
nearby
status alert search protocols active
noise investigating anomalous simulated
gunfire
weird
very beat
[Music]
you up
oh right
take people down
auditorium
very strategic
i knew you'd save me my um spiderman
patrol
anomalies initiated
auditory alert possible intruder alert
unknown hostile nearby
step alert search behavior
remember you can take down guys while
crawling on walls too
man the passages are all pete
that's funny
kind of weird
very beat
[Music]
you up
oh right okay
very strategic
i knew you'd save me my um spiderman
amazing
disturbance detected
alert possible hostile nearby auditory
alert possible intruder
battle evil mark
someone will save me please
[Music]
i think you're at the ultimate level now
buddy
just read huge success
[Music]
now that you've gotten the hang of them
stealth takedowns will give you a boost
in power nothing like being in the
stealth zone gotta remember to bust out
a few stoke takedowns next time
[Music]
those convicts look lost
think i should point them back to the
raft
i'm making art over here spiderman mind
your own business unfortunately today
your terrible art is my business
show me what you got
[Music]
come on guys isn't new york traffic bad
enough
someone's robbing a feast truck
what is wrong with people
need to keep that beast driver safe from
those robbers listen to the man stealing
from the homeless
that's a new low even for you loser
you're gonna be okay
that's not all of them just stay down
i'll handle them
i want
you bystander reported people messing
with the feast delivery truck
i've got bobcall
someone's robbing a beach truck
what is wrong with people
right
that's not all of them
you wait
oh
[Music]
grab them
and no one gets hurt
we're here for the goods the spiderman
fan out and secure the area
[Music]
they're done it's all good
this car chase is about to turn into a
web chaser
hello
keep going boys just gotta make it to
the state
[Applause]
faster than line
keep
it
up
that isn't good
what do these guys have evil back up on
speed dial
maybe that'll teach you to stay in your
lane
howard
oh
pigeon guy
pete told me about him let's see what he
needs
the underground must be nearby if
they're hijacking that billboard
gotta lock on to the signal sucker
locating the source
got it i'm locked on
if the underground wants more press
maybe they should try opening up an
alpaca farm
i'd read about that
the underground as advertised
hey i had some notes on your billboard
campaign got a minute
wow
and done
maybe the underground should try handing
out pamphlets next time
someone caught a weapons deal had
you looking out people
[Music]
don't think those guns are for paintball
spiderman get him out of here i'm sorry
spider-man frown on unauthorized arm
dealings
they don't want to be spider-man
you're dead
yes
[Music]
keeping the neighborhood safe from rock
song weapons spider-man style
[Music]
as if new york wasn't exciting enough
during the holidays there is now a
tropical storm
hurricane creeping its way up the coast
oh yeah just like that movie where the
boat gets swept over by a big wave you
know
oh
anyway this storm hits a lot of people
so now it's a great time to donate to
your local shelter
until next time remember to check your
credit score annually you get one free
report per year so be responsible bye
[Applause]
this would have been easier with a house
call you know i don't do house calls
since they'll rob me last year oh yeah
like your italian i hired her she's got
a gift for
persuasion
so have her guard you
he saw everything yeah those better be
water guns but they're not disgusting
i'm back
now stop driving
stop stop stop stop
be more subtle next time or you know
just don't do crimes
christmas
[Music]
app says wrapped escapees took hostages
and blocked off the street
[Music]
[Applause]
happy
hey molasses
up here
fire escapes shakier than it used to be
careful on the way up
[Music]
so
this is why you wanted to meet here
almost failed you took so long
give me a hand it's stuck
time capsule's seen better days
you remember the combination
yeah it's uh
oh man it's uh
you kidding me y'all gotta start
remembering this code not always gonna
be around to tell you well remember
we'll remember well remember yeah yeah
good now uh what are you gonna put
inside this bad boy secret time capsule
only miles and i know
boom that's right keep it secret keep it
safe hey rick
you're gonna take that job at roxanne or
what
why you gonna take it if i don't maybe
waiting to see the offer okay
competition eh well they're talking a
good game want me to uh lead their clean
energy group and you know me
clean power and save the world
i love my nerdy fan club oh
speaking of devil roxon back in a second
you remember the code right
um
the fibonacci sequence nice
our award
i mean our energy converter was pretty
fire truth
you think it's still on display at the
science center
hope so
wow
look at this
goober central
rig looking suave as ever though yeah
something going on with him
you guys fight or something no
no fight
finn it's fine
why do we really lose touch
[Music]
crap now i'm late
i gotta go
hey
i feel like we both have stuff we're not
sharing next time we hang
no secrets
okay
yeah
maybe
if you're on time
see you soon short stuff
you know i'm taller than you now right
not in here
[Music]
middle school graduation was bittersweet
finn went man
it was so good to see finn
i should find other time capsules we hid
but a little later i gotta get home from
mom's rally
good time to use